what's up guys we're pon finiti this
challenge episode we took your ideas
from Instagram and we literally got
thousands of requests let's see what we
got
[Music]
[Music]
so there's 70% of you guys you still
haven't subscribed at - remember - that
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
felt like my hand come up okay let's try
and play with chopsticks
[Music]
oh three in a row now you're gonna miss
[Music]
[Applause]
three tries
[Music]
[Music]
this is good practice for what I'm gonna
eat Chinese food next it's gonna be
let's go for the double around the net
[Music]
[Applause]
that's just waiting
okay let's try it out the flying little
ball this seems like an interesting idea
well let's see how many shots we can get
it gets made bit through there maybe
three one for each ball
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so that was a cool idea didn't
really quite work out as we were hoping
to work dinner but remembered subscribe
and watch our previous episodes there
until next time
[Applause]